Here is a quick and easy full needle
rib cast on that's just two rows.
Now, before you try this, be sure you
understand racking on your machine.
Review this video if you need help.
The instructions for this cast
on start with rack H or swing H.
Pull up a few needles and confirm
that your ribber is set to half pitch.
The needles should be aligned like this.
Now, because we'll be creating stitches
on all needles, be sure to use a yarn
that is finer than you
might normally knit ribbing.
Set both beds for plain knitting.
No tuck or slip buttons
or levers are engaged.
Set both carriages to the main tension
for your garment or slightly tighter.
Start by creating a zigzag row
by knitting from right to left.
Hang the cast-on comb,
aligning it to the center and taking
care not to split any stitches.
Hang weights as needed.
Swing your ribber to the right
so that the needles are aligned like this.
No matter what machine you're using,
make sure that the needles are
not crashing into each other.
Notice that the stitches
are skewed to the right.
Knit one row to the right.
Now, rack back to the left, and
your needles should now be
in the original position.
Again, half pitch,
and they're not crashing into each other.
And continue knitting.
Using the wire weight hangers can help.
The cast-on is complete, and this is
called a full needle rib racked cast-on.
This is a really fast cast-on,
but it's fairly loose, and the cast-on
comb can distort that first row.
Don't try and tighten the first
two rows of this cast-on.
The stitches need to be loose
or large enough to rack.
Consider casting on with waste yarn.
Knit a few rows and then
knit one row of ravel cord.
Thread up the carriage with the main
garment yarn and repeat that racked
cast on over that ravel cord.
When you're done with your piece,
you can remove the ravel cord and you've
protected that cast on edge
from the cast on comb.